oui alors voilà d'abord il faut il faut
savoir que y aura une convention sur la
justice il a dit très bien que nous
sommes là sur un point qui est le point
le plus connu de l'action de la justice
c'est à dire la justice et la sécurité
la justice se limite pas à ça mais c'est
le sujet essentiel d'aujourd'hui et
c'est d'ailleurs la préoccupation
essentielle et français il faut savoir
que nous avons vécu une longue dérive en
matière de droit pénal en effet à partir
d'un une certaine forme d'esprit des
magistrats de plus en plus pénétrer
d'idéaux d'origine probablement marxiste
mal compris on a vu naître un syndicat
de la magistrature aux opinions
politiques bien précises
et tout cela aboutit finalement un
système juridique alors que le code
pénal est un col législatif
essentiellement que la source du droit
essentiel première c'est la loi on a vu
progressivement les magistrats en droit
pénal
ben se substituer de plus en plus à
diminution de peine en droit pénal pour
des options idéologiques substituant
ainsi à l'autorité de la loi
au fond un jugement qui était le leur et
seulement le leur c'est la raison pour
laquelle lorsque nous avons abordé la
question des peines planchers j'essaye
de rendre simple quelque chose qui est
très compliquée lorsque nous avons
abordé la question des peines plancher
au fond c'était une résistance à cette
tendance des juges à aller à la
diminution de la sanction pénale et pour
les obliger même lorsqu'il était très
favorable à cette diminution à le
justifier par écrit c'est à dire en
prenant leurs responsabilités
ces peines plancher ont été voter dès
c'était une très bonne chose après de
longs débats et d'ailleurs le conseil
constitutionnel qui a été saisi sur ce
sujet a montré que nous étions
parfaitement avec ses peines plancher
qui interdisent donc d'aller au dessous
de la sanction prévue par la loi sauf
exception nous étions tout à fait dans
la norme du droit du droit des principes
généraux de notre droit
c'était le premier point le deuxième
point eh bien nous avons évidemment rang
or c'est à partir des peines planchers
le barème des peines applicables et je
dois dire que nous avons répondu ainsi à
ce que l'opinion souhaiter car la
justice
elle est faite et le code pénal c'est un
code presque primaire est fait pour
répondre à une angoisse de la population
l'angoissent de la population c'est
qu'elle ne se sentait pas en sécurité et
que par conséquent il était de voir du
gouvernement conformément aux principes
généraux et sans y déroger d'appliquer
les sanctions qu'ils soient des
sanctions fermes et appliqué c'est ce
que nous avons fait ensuite nous avons
parce que nous avions fait des sanctions
fermes pour répondre à la petite
remarque de georges tout à l'heure c'est
vrai que nous avons nous mêmes nous
sommes entrés dans le système dans un
système d'applicabilité des peines dont
l'application a été incertaine mais il
faut bien comprendre qu'à cette époque
lorsque nous sommes rentrés dans ce
sujet c'est parce que nous aimions
alourdi les peines et que
l'alourdissement des peines pour vers la
limite se justifier sur la question de
l'exécution avec madame taubira
tout est tombé par terre c'est à dire le
syndicat de la magistrature politiser à
l'extrême a repris les commandes de la
chancellerie
et bien entendu nous avons eu
l'abrogation des peines planchers nous
avons eu la vocation aussi de tous les
systèmes qui étaient des six thèmes
récurrents qui nous permettait d'imposer
une entrée en prison et d'y rester
et donc nous sommes devant le système
taubira qui est en réalité le système
qui est le plus détesté le plus
détestable que nous pouvions avoir dans
l'application du droit pénal
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
que très simplement et on en discutera
dans la convention sur la justice
il faudra prendre des résolutions fortes
pour redonner une confiance aux français
de redonner confiance en notre justice
pénale pour ça eh bien il faudra
rétablir évidemment les peines plancher
non seulement sur la récidive mais sur
la réitération
or c'est un peu compliqué mais enfin
c'est très simple la récidive
s'acidifient que le délit ou qu'ils
aient commis
est identique à celui qui a été
précédemment commis la réitération
permet d'élargir la récidive à toute
action délictuelle qui viendrait
s'ajouter à aux délits précédents
donc c'est un élargissement tout à fait
souhaitable que nous allons rétablir et
dans l'application des peines et bien
georges en a parlé tout à l'heure il me
paraît évident que désormais
l'application des peines doit aboutir
fermement à la mise en prison de ceux
qui sont condamnés à la prison et que
par conséquent nous allons suggérer
nicolas on parlera tout à l'heure au
président l'évoquera en détail nous
allons suggérer de réformes et cette loi
de revenir à une application plus
naturel de la sécurité dans le domaine
de la justice est imposé que toute loi
tout tout délit condamné à une peine
supérieure à six mois de prison et bien
soit exécutée dans le cadre carcéral qui
appose effectivement un certain nombre
de dispositions de construction de
prisons
tout cela est logique a une
signification quand on nous dit vous ne
respectez pas la justice nous respectons
nous mieux que les autres la justice
c'est la justice elle même qui ne se
respectent plus par rapport à elle même
car une justice qui est tellement
décriée qui est tellement mal perçue par
une opinion ce n'est pas ce n'est pas à
l'opinion qu'il faut en randonnée le
grief
c'est aux juges eux-mêmes alors on nous
dit une ronde critique pas les jus enfin
moi je suis professeur à la faculté
droit ça me fait rigoler d'entendre dire
qu'il faut pas critiquer les juges
j'arrête pas de le faire moi dans la
gazette du palais sinon c'est plus la
peine d'avoir des revues juridiques si
c'est pour avoir du droit trop ne peux
pas commenter c'est pas la peine
cela pour faire une petite référence par
ailleurs à une actualité brûlante
soyons clair ce sont ces l'injustice et
là l'idée de la justice et de la
sécurité qu'il faut reconstituer
c'est ça notre combat s'est pas entraîné
une déqualification logis c'est le
contraire c'est la requalifier loin la
justice pénale lui redonner son droit
et dire que dans ce pays la justice et
la sécurité ne sont pas incompatibles
elles sont au contraire
solidaires pour assurer la sécurité qui
est la première des libertés
merci